[Music]
wars
guys we're going to watch today the book
of boba fett
episode 4. use the force to leave a like
that would be amazeballs also subscribe
so you can get notified when our
reaction for the next boba fett episode
is up as always full-length watch
alongside single with the time coder
over at our patreon page thank you to
all become sparrowjax by checking all we
got to offer over there lastly thanks to
the boys of red prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights you guys are
so good at what you do
and i'll never give you a raise never
your droids droids you're dead meat we
can replace you in a heartbeat yeah
you're just parts man they don't watch
these intros idiots
[Music]
[Music]
must be pretty matted bit 429 jabba
still too many guards
let's get something to eat
feels like running would be faster
oh [ __ ] it's the mandalorian episode
the chapter five one mystery feet
so cool after two seasons to confirm
that that's pretty cool
[Music]
oh i think this is what people have been
waiting for how they became best friends
oh [ __ ] so he's met them before or at
least they're ilk
i'm going to see the words as a person
yeah
no walk-ins appointment only
this woman is about to die
well you should have started with that
you don't even know how much it is yeah
it could be like a few few credits
[Music]
nas is so cyberpunk uh
[Music]
it's the color of the bikes
[Laughter]
easter egg
what happened
you were dying of a gut shot i saved
your life
now i behave evil
trust me
who are you i am boba fett
he's just mastered that delivery
he's born to be this guy speed bikers
defeated tuscans
that's highly unlikely i want you to
help me help me recover my fire spray
gunship slave
if i help you
my debt is paid that is what you wish oh
you're gonna want to be his best friend
after this
the ship's there right let's take a
closer look
[Music]
awesome
it's like that mapping ball from
prometheus
that's cool it's like a stealth mission
it's time to say farewell my friend
you served me well
oh
buddy
i know i'm gonna miss you too
now go
find other banters make baby banthas
go
oh
he loves you the panthers keep getting
shot down in this show you know you fast
how many carcasses now
[ __ ]
what's next for you i'm gonna find my
armor
mandalorian season two
it's like a video game yeah yeah check
the map
[Music]
this is so cool really getting to see
like jabba's palace
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like slicing the guy's throat about
to be a general grievous fight
[Music]
guys
making so much noise
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm gonna take my time
i'm gonna enjoy this
[Laughter]
he just committed droid suicide can we
go now
let's go i want to be taken seriously
it's like a boba fett christmas special
right there
yeah
okay
[Music]
they did an amazing job sneaking past
everyone
are they the same too i think that would
be fun
they really are terrible terrible guards
i know
how they get this job
there are so many
[Music]
slave one i am boba fett
[Laughter]
let's get out of here
[Music]
i'd love to work for that man one day
i need to get the gate open but i can't
see a thing i'm a little busy here
no
terrible guards
[Music]
yeah seriously without her none of this
would be possible
oh
awesome
[Music]
good thing that
i thought it might have a scene with bib
how's the ship
she's in good shape just a little rusty
they're good mechanics in mos eisley
i'll do the maintenance myself
oh oh come on
pelle motto man
now you'll dance paid
get out of here would you like to be
dropped
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] settle them scores boba
yeah you are no match for the slave one
oh oh damn shot yeah
vengeance
[Music]
that's me
[Laughter]
i am boba fett
[Music]
that's where i was trapped all those
years ago that's where that [ __ ] ate
me my armor yeah
it's dissolved
not biscuit
oh it sucks no he's gonna do all this
work and
wow
jeez
that's a great shot you know the way
they handle the flashbacks are solid
[Laughter]
ah the beak is hiding deep within
oh yeah
[Music]
oh it's one of the cannon blasters yeah
fire in the hall
yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he they murdered this the
freaking starlight yeah talk about some
revenge
next time don't touch my buttons
nothing
oh junk
search that whole sarlacc how many times
have you been hired to do a job that was
avoidable
i'm tired of our kind dying because of
the idiocy of others
we're smarter than them it's time we
took our shot
we
we've become self-employed
who are freelancers
i need brains and muscle
you have both
yeah she's done so much without really
[Laughter]
living with the tuscans has made you
soft
no
it's made me strong
can only get so far without a tribe
a cool journey
oh so we're like [ __ ] caught up now
yeah we're caught up yeah
damn
uh what's uh triggering him so much
loretta he's alone he's got no friends
what are you doing dude
in this more civilized place in these
more civilized times
what was once celebrated and the
bloodlust of the arena is now seen as
horror
and cruelty
is that of his time so what say you
release this customer and let these fine
folks get back to their fun and in
return i will wipe your debt off the
books
free drinks
dude
i got the arm off
you can't do star wars without chopping
off someone's arm looks like you could
use a job
yeah obviously you remember
when you let him go you were all once
captains under the hut
but you quickly left the family when
fortuna claimed to be the heir this is
so godfather
why do you deserve to be the daimyo what
prevents us all from killing you and
taking what we want okay love the makeup
oh they kept it at me
yes
right on cue
please
sit i tend to with respect
i will make the streets safe again so
all in this room can prosper all i ask
in return is that you remain neutral if
the pike syndicate approaches you to
betray me
okay we won't betray you
do anything sounds good i abide
this figures are makeup so they can't
turn their heads
by the way
we must prepare for war how much
treasure do we have in reserve i have
plenty of credits
what i'm short on is muscle credits can
buy muscle
if you know where to look
did you hear it
come on
look at that crossover going what a
great indicator didn't jordan all we
need is that theme
nice well done kevin tancharon
so the even number episodes are the best
the ones that are longer and take their
time
better yeah exactly
what is that the reverse of star trek
yeah
even numbered ones suck
yeah star trek city even numbers are
good
then just all of sci-fi
evens
interesting this concept art would imply
that he had his uniform by then yeah
but i mean how cool is that it's like
it's cool how pathetic operates as like
a consigliere mm-hmm
yeah she's like robert dewfall mm-hmm or
billy crystal
sweet dicks hey they got the
christopher macquarie photo
that's right
christopher now chris mcquarrie
copper
i am boba fett
such authority
it's my dream is to see uh
boba fett take on covet
yeah or you know in everyday situations
what's the name for this drink which is
i require a pcr test
that's good you're getting better at
that
that's pretty good i'm going to get the
cadence down by the end of this series
he has mastered that he's got verses
his like there's like a rhythm there's
like a dance to him it's like as little
as you can move your lower jaw keep it
at the back of your throat
i love when it's all dirty because it
really brings out how glistening white
his teeth is a great dental plan oh yeah
they really took care of him on camino
there there's a deleted scene where the
mod guy just cleaned up his teeth
i require a toothbrush
that's a
yeah this is a great one this is great
it's about i oh wow copper agrees hey
i would say that this is probably the
best one so far i would say listen to
this and two yeah yeah yeah cause
getting the whole like you know deep
dive into uh tuscan culture is great but
this one has like a means of wrapping it
back around to where we first got the
hints of boba fett and the man
yeah it almost begs you to stop and say
that like it's an accident
yeah no you're absolutely right well i
think it's just the most exciting one
because now we're caught up we're seeing
it tied in it's filling in that blank of
a chapter five that we we know is filled
in because of mandalorians my god copper
i can't it's 1 30 in the morning i can't
just go play with you right now
yeah
um
yeah it's filling in that that like the
gap there of when we saw him appear for
what episode was that the fourth episode
already yesterday i think it was the
fourth one
um when we officially saw boba and
fennick together when slave one showed
up on the planet yeah and uh revealed
like their stomach with the mod device
in there with the mod upgrades in there
so you really see like how the
relationship um ultimately came to be
you learn why boba's really doing this
like you can like fill in why and it was
kind of obvious but a lot of people i've
seen a lot of people go like why it
makes no sense someone's pretty obvious
um and so to see that to have that
conversation flesh out but no just it's
like
what i thought was cool about this was
that it had the fun
because of the fact of everything that
it's answering
homie
it had it had the fun of everything that
it's answering because of you know my
neck hat is really throwing me off my
game right now
okay
it's filling in the blank because of
everything like i've said this like
several times at this point
five times over now you fill in the
blank what blank the show was filling
um fill in those blanks but also because
it's haven't it's adapted more of the
tone and the breathing and the pacing of
episode two something that really took
its time significantly more like all
these episodes ought to be like 45
minutes to an hour for that breathing
space
but it's fun because you're also seeing
like fennec shan being here and then the
mod upgrades and then how he retrieved
slave one so you're doing so many things
in here that just by nature of covering
it it's just more fun you know so yeah
that's also great like this whole thing
with fennec shand and even the motto
because i feel like there's a lot of
criticism towards that department but
this time we got to go in there see how
some of the surgery is done it had that
true oh my goodness
see this is what i'm dealing with guys
literally like bringing in a cat toy
like come play with me guys right now
come play with me
i know it's 1 30 in the morning but
you're awake i'm your
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you got to calm down buddy
um
yeah so uh
so then yeah you have um yeah the whole
thing with going in there which i love
like the cyberpunk five so i thought
it'd be a little bit i mean uh obviously
wouldn't be what if you were to tell me
the concept i would probably imagine it
would be a little bit grittier bloodier
grizzlier kind of like elysium yeah a
little bit even though we had some of
the the moving parts which kind of feel
like terminator or even down to uh luke
skywalker and empire yeah yeah so you're
like you're seeing the gears and what
they might do physically yeah i don't
like the choice so i i thought it was
actually well justified of the choice of
why they wouldn't close it up when he's
when he says that to him like why don't
you close it up why hide the word well i
had the work because these people liked
that and respected it i'm wondering you
know what the evolution of the mod
upgrades might be over the course of
this show or the live action series in
general something that is more on the
forefront or a little more predominant
to kind of in your face a bit more but
even like with boba i mean um when
fennek waking up and i thought like
seeing that in her perspective words you
know even like the way he says it
but he's like i saved your life and
you're seeing her point of view of how
this probably seems threatening to her
when we know it's not obviously
uh however i think what this does a good
job on doing like a lot of the camera
work i thought did a great job on
capturing perspective like there's some
really unique shots
and tonally a lot of just wonderful
moments here i just like the emotion of
this a lot mm-hmm you know yeah and boba
doing this because of uh you know like
he said it a couple times uh he's sick
of dealing with idiots
and yeah that's what i mean by filling
in the blank of that we could have done
ourselves of yeah this guy's been like a
bounty hunter forever and he's been
involved with gangs he's he's
literally done nothing but observe an
answer to people yeah his whole life and
he's reached a point now where he's had
a second chance he's been reborn in more
ways than one he's also more wise after
his experiences with the tuscan raiders
why wouldn't he go after this and even
even explaining specifically why fennec
would be interested yeah and i mean i've
heard some gripes from people online
about yeah like why why would boba do
certain such and such a thing but i i
appreciated the breath with which
they've gotten you know we're in the
middle of the season now and to finally
have that at least directly from him
basically saying yeah i i did that for
so long and then finally i i found a
tribe and i learned you know sort of
you can still be you know an incredible
warrior but also some type of community
is essential and is important and you
know in this world it probably is wiser
than just being
yeah a lone bounty undergoing and
getting involved in the affairs of a
bunch of people who have messy affairs
which does make me wish we saw a little
bit more time with it like if this whole
season was just
the past yeah probably would have been
cool with that because we could have
really seen just how because i'm kind of
lost on how much time he spent with the
tuscan raiders
and i would have liked to have seen all
the things that he was really learning
to see why he's sort of changed this
much to adopting these philosophies more
about uh like power and numbers power
and community as a as opposed to you
know being the lone bounty hunter
um but still like what we got here with
this character development
i think it lines up really well and then
even for fennick to be enticed to this
like she doesn't exactly want to be a
leader but she could be a solid number
two in an operation like this yeah you
know well and what's her episode in a
lot of ways too absolutely and i love
the the relationship they're drawing
between the two of them like i love
how they are just you know these two
peas almost in a pod and it's a little
green hornet a little bit
like the dynamic yeah and because she's
full on asian like bruce lee was or not
yeah i'm doing that
no it's the it's the it's the thing i'm
like yeah it's a great horror show but
it's you know it's like look at cato
stealing the spotlight kicking all the
ass yeah well i love that how fennick is
always the one like you want me to go do
something about it like you know i can
go take some action for you boss um but
yeah like they're going back to the
thing you said about perspectives like
yeah i love how at first you can kind of
see why she would be suspect of him and
then slowly he sort of gains her
confidence and her trust and her respect
and yeah like she is his consilieri in a
lot of ways and i love and not that you
know it's like there's no hinting it's
like it doesn't have to be a romantic
thing of any kind it's just they are
these two their partners and their they
seem like friends
you know and i love that they have a
bond like that where they are just this
duo who really is carving this new path
oh my god step by step
on speed dating
[Music]
how many times in a night does he get
this thing
tell me all your interests and hobbies
i think this is a negotiation for the
day will it be compatible
[Laughter]
i will be taking you to dinner
yes
i want no there's so many situations i
want to see yeah yeah yeah
but uh but yeah i just really like the
relationship and and the dynamic they've
drawn between them because it's it's
really badass but it also has a lot of
humor in it and it also has yeah that
element of trust and of community even
they're they're just two people that
element of community that they can then
build this sort of ever growing
organization on top of
and yeah like the the way they brought
it around it's like i feel like you
could have done this
part of me really likes the motif of
having the flashbacks in the present
side by side and if this becomes some
kind of an appendix to the mandalorian
like if din jarring comes back and then
mandalorian season three involves both
of them if din jarring comes away when
dinger
made it next week that's the music queue
whatever if they played darth vader's
two now like what
is it
um but then after we left off it's
obvious oh yeah it's going back sorry a
poor choice of words next week it's
still an if cause well firm but yeah
what i'm getting at is that i could
imagine this going in a way where you
know we get this crucial piece of
information and background on what
boba's been doing up until this point
where he is in the present yeah as
it pertains to the mandalorian you know
part of me is like well maybe
mandalorian season three will have them
both involved or something like this or
maybe boba fett's gonna spin right off
but either way i i think they've done a
really nice job of justifying this and
yeah it's like you could have done it
where you had the first half of the show
just be all the flashbacks leading into
the present and in some ways yeah you
could have had more
uh you know just in-depth moments with
the tuscans and whatnot but as it stands
for what we've got here i think these
past couple episodes have done a nice
job of balancing that past and present
and uh and yeah seeing the mirror sides
the the sort of relief sides of what was
happening when yeah we got that tease of
boba stepping in on fennec shannon the
first season of mandalorian and then you
know knowing that we'll probably
dovetail into that season two episode
next week uh you know is is like they've
drawn it in a geographical time way
that's really fun but that also feels
contained to its own thing and i think
that's that's quite nice yeah absolutely
um and then yeah of course going through
like retrieving slave one seeing how we
got that shipped back because i didn't
know where slave was located so then to
see that was in java's palace which
makes me kind of wish we did have a big
fortuna um encounter especially because
like the tease for this show at the end
of mandalorian was that he would that he
kills big fortuna and i like seeing like
fat ass before dude you know i wanted to
kind of get some something there that
maybe made that a little bit more
personal
when he does kill him as opposed to just
dethroning him at that moment like he
had his reasons and feeling [ __ ] over
and whatnot but i still think that that
would have made that post credit scene
have a little bit more weight to it but
i thought the sequence of it was a neat
setup i like that it became
you know this bargain struck of sneaking
in going through the palace felt very
video game like would have even liked it
to be even longer honestly if we're
having to sneak past all these guards
but i was cool when it did build up into
the chaos them having to get away
and then they're like they're having
this like crazy shootout uh as they're
and they bring like a lot of there's a
lot of meaning towards slave one for
boba fett because that is is fathership
so to
inherit i could see why that was so
personal for me to get it like why not
just get another ship no it's his and
and there's a lot of meaning to that
same way how the armor means a lot to
him as well
so seeing these other sides of the
of jabba's palace and like we didn't see
too much we saw like it was like to see
like some different locations as the
place is freaking massive and we tend to
just go to the one spot where the throne
is yeah where the rancor is located down
below and so we don't really see much of
java's palace or like the entrance way
with the doors
so uh
wait a minute i'm thinking
geographically about this
because slave one looked like it was
located where the entrance doors were
just was just there the whole time where
the entrance doors were i guess so yeah
it was just right there yeah i had to go
into that little thing or to the right
yeah okay
march right in there but that's how it
read to me as like that big door
right there too big
just leave it right there leave it in
the garage
yeah like the way that sequence was done
and um you know it's like only bobo
would really know how to fly that ship
and i would compile this thing with me
it's a very specific ship oh yeah then
it seems like it's really you have to
have experience of piloting it so really
showing the strength of the of
putting these two together fennec and
boba putting them together about like
boba's piloting while fenix do it like
and that scene it does perceive as like
fenix doing most of the work but i'm
like
he's gonna find out he's gonna get this
thing moving yeah yeah exactly but in
that moment it is one statement seems
like she's doing way more work right now
and you could not do this alone
definitely um and then even going to the
sarlacc pick like i like that they added
that detail even as audience members
knowing full well
like we've seen mandalorian season two
we know
how he gets his armor back like we know
that but in terms of character
we also
seem a little would register a little
odd to me if he didn't try to get his
armor back from the sarlacc pit if you
believed it was still located in there
and it also adds more meaning to the
fact that he of all those scenes of
mandalorian season two of why that armor
meant so much to him the fact that he
would risk his life again literally it's
like a suicide mission going in there
and again fennec safe today yeah
i wonder how some people feel about that
honestly because it part of me does make
me go i wish i do wish boba was the one
who to kill the sarlacc yeah after
everything i do have that feeling as
well and so i wonder if some people
might feel that way so i thought it was
a great moment to bring back that
um i don't know what that's called it
can't it's in mandalorian season two and
it's an attack of the clones during the
like asteroid battle that big blue
cannon ball thingy that oh she named it
even yeah i forget what it's called um
but to to see
to see that brought back and used to
effect to kill the sorrow like i would
have thought like the cool cathartic
moment would have been for boba to do it
himself yeah 100
um but then you got like these other
things they've been setting up you know
like and also like oh the action scene
of like killing the bikers like that was
one of those really great stuff oh dude
yeah of getting that revenge and even
boppa's face just like feeling his
vengeance in his eyes you know quite
cathartic and i think it's those little
quiet moments why a character like
fennick would connect to him because
it's she's seeing that like this isn't
really about money this is something
more personal everything this whole this
whole objective is personal well yeah
and they're cut from similar cloth and
obviously they're both used to being
bounty hunters and i think it's i think
it's a cool turn for him to be like yeah
i've lived this whole life
enough to kind of understand the
different levels of it and now i'm going
to try and take what i know and make my
own operation that's better than all
those other
buffoon run operations and so yeah it
makes a lot of sense the way that they
gradually kind of get onto the same page
and it's funny because i feel like this
is the main if i ever have a complaint
it's usually that she's like i just want
to see more of this or this or this um
but i think what what makes this episode
partly so fun is that you get a lot of
really you know satisfying story moving
forward
but you also get it's like the first
episode had these callback elements and
here you have them again you have the
sarlacc again and you get slave one for
the first time in this series at least
in the present and it's like you have
you know the continuation and the
fleshing out of boba and fenix story but
also now in this fourth episode you get
a whole bunch of your classic easter
eggs again sure so i feel like yeah you
can kind of connect them in a very fun
way that's also it's like two layers
running parallel
and uh and i like that they even had the
much maligned sarlacc beak in there just
hiding internally yeah
it was a scary moment that actually got
me that little jump moment yeah
absolutely and uh full time it was like
there were some great shots in there too
like i thought that was shot really well
like the perspective of being in the
mouth yeah it was awesome
um and you know like the way they're
setting up things like characters like
black croissant and getting a history of
the past with him of his his gladiator
days like his former glory days and now
at a place where he doesn't belong like
i i you know it struck me as odd when he
just let him go that one time yeah in
the last episode of you think after you
know he's bubba strikes me as a kind of
leader who's like you got potential let
me hire you yeah you know you have
nowhere to belong let me hire you
because like la croissant and i think
what they've done with him is they like
whoever's playing him uh brings that the
makeup and the costume to life so well
like you just feel a person underneath
there and
the eyes yeah yeah the look in the eyes
of seeing just uh you know the
loneliness like oh this guy's actually
just like lost right now
yeah
and like she's the lady who said that
that hot ass twilight lady who's like
you know it's better now see we're good
i'm like that's not better to do is
remind him of who he used to be and how
his life isn't good his life isn't what
he lives for it doesn't match this new
world that he's in geez and i even uh
enjoyed the scene that was really
godfather reminiscent of you know boba
working his way up with all the families
and establishing uh you know like what's
to come like they're setting up this war
really well you know if you got black
croissant in here that obviously they're
going to go after the houses as boba
describes these the pike characters but
i i do think that this show could
probably do a little bit of a better job
at setting up the pike syndicate for
audiences who haven't seen like clone
wars or something like that so that way
they would know like just how much of a
threat they really are or what power
they can really wield but right now as
it stands i do think it's doing a good
enough job with showing like they
haven't he hasn't fully earned their
respect just yet to the point where they
are fearful of him i i'm even like that
but they would still betray him if
enough money look if coin was thrown
their way
but the way how that whole scene is
handled and how he's not demanding a lot
he's just prepping them in advance that
you know it's like he's planting the
seeds that our lives will probably be
necessary one day and like whatever the
war is that is coming they've teased it
a couple of times now you know having
mando on your side black croissant and
fennec whoever else they can get maybe
more mandalorians will come into the
fold where this could be like boba
fett's official
um you know adjacent mandalorian
indoctrination in some way
of like he is a man like viewed as a
mandalorian can you imagine one of those
shots all those mandalorians rocketed
yeah
we got you well it's like the way how
fennec responded to him of like boba
fett's dead you know like shows that he
does have a legacy in this world in some
way and whereas like then jordan didn't
know who he was um
from the assassin's creed they knew who
he was so yeah there's a lot to
unpacking i really thought this episode
was great but guys what'd you think
about it leave your thoughts down below
why don't you go ahead subscribe click
that bell hit that like button last but
not least let's do a page
sarah campbell i would jump into a
sarlacc after you if you were in peril
my first
notion would be i gotta save you and i
gotta do it in style if you were in
trouble i would steal the nearest ship
and i would mow down whatever biker gang
has stolen you away from us because
you're a traveler you're an
intergalactic kind of gal all right
you're liable to find yourself someplace
exotic but maybe with prying eyes about
maybe with somebody that you'll need
saving from hey maybe you be the finnick
shane you'll kick all their asses
yourself but either way we would be
there for you because you have been
there for us over so much time you are
one of the longer enduring patrons here
and we super duper appreciate that and
i can't believe to some extent that you
still are with us on this journey but
hey i am overjoyed and heartened every
time i see your name pop up so i hope
that you're doing well
and stay out of trouble out there in
this big old galaxy of ours
much love and we'll catch you on the
next one see ya sarah thank you
[Music]